I was very much struck by how the
translation of the biblical writings
jump started the development of literacy
across the entire world illiteracy was
the norm the pastor's home was the first
school and every morning it would begin
with singing the Christian faith is a
singing religion probably 80 percent of
Scripps memorization today exists only
because of what is sung this is amazing
here we have a Gutenberg Bible printed
on the Press of Johann goonberg science
and religion are opposing forces in the
world but historically that has not been
the case now the book is available to
everyone from Shakespeare to modern
education and medicine and science to to
civilization itself it is the most
influential book in all history and
hopefully people can walk away with at
least a sense of that
if
democratically people want to address
this issue that is their right but
secondly you must do so on an informed
basis and you must look for high quality
policy and you won't get that without a
good debate and if you ask me to make a
trade between saving the planet tonight
on a on a whim and feeding people I'm
sorry I'm going with feeding people
you've got to have
conviction you've got to be guided by
the data you've got to actually think
facts matter taking people with you
matters the fundamental spirit that has
imbued the West is the only spirit that
has ever actually lifted people who are
oppressed out of their oppression yeah
and so what that means is this I believe
that the radical critique that's been
aimed at Western culture in the name of
freedom for oppression is actually
attacking the very spirit that has
lifted people out of Oppression to the
degree that that's been the case if
there's no intrinsic worth that's Divine
in some sense so sacred
then why can't I just do with you what I
want if I have the power but I don't see
how you can make a moral case that if I
can do it I shouldn't if you're going to
make the moral case you have to make the
assumption that
each person in some sense is created in
the image of what is sacred and you
can't violate that regardless of
apparent evidence for hierarchical
difference
foreign
I'm just concluding my tour
in New Zealand and Australia with a
wrap-up discussion with
Mr John Anderson and so I'm looking
forward to that and I hope you all find
it valuable The Honorable John Anderson
AC ftse spent 19 years in the Australian
Parliament this included six years as
Deputy Prime Minister as a member of the
reformist government led by John Howard
amongst other step changing initiatives
this government oversaw enormous
economic reform including Taxation
modernization and the maintenance of a
string of miraculous budget surpluses
which resulted in leaving a cash Surplus
on leaving office in 2007.
since then John has remained active in
public commentary various advisory
bodies and in the not-for-profit sector
he's been a sought-after speaker in both
Australia and abroad
in recent years he's hosted a successful
YouTube and podcast interview series
I've been on that a couple of times the
preeminent one of its kind in Australia
he was made a companion of the order of
Australia in 2022 the nation's highest
Civic honor for his various services to
the community
on leaving politics Anderson known for
his character in Christian faith was
saluted by figures on both sides with
praise the then prime minister John
Howard said I've not met a person with
greater Integrity in public life I'm
looking very much forward to talking to
John for YouTube today and then also
following that up as I frequently do
with an additional half an hour on the
daily wire plus platform walking through
his bio and thanks to the Daily wire
types for facilitating these
conversations welcome to all of you who
are watching and listening
so Mr Anderson I thought we could
start talking
by discussing something that you
accomplished along with other members of
your government
several years ago
you managed to run a sequence of
balanced budgets and to also pay down a
substantial part or all of Australia's
debt in a relatively short period of
time all of Australia is a federal debt
of Australia's federal debt and money in
the bank and left money in the bank okay
and so what year is over did that over
what years did that take place began in
and the future fund with surpluses and
sales from revenue sales from a couple
of assets would then put aside as a
wealth fund if you like for the future
and from memory about 206 207 just in
time for the great financial crisis
so Australia went into the great
financial crisis with no debt money in
the bank at a federal government level
okay so how why don't we delve a little
bit into exactly what that means because
there's a bunch of mysteries there the
first mystery is I suppose
why that hadn't happened before
then the second mystery is how did you
possibly manage it and the third mystery
is given that it was possible and that
you demonstrated it was possible why did
that stop happening and why did more
countries around the world also not do
the same thing so let's start with the
first one which was
why did the governments prior to the one
that you were integrally involved in
find it necessary to run at a deficit
and rack up a tremendous debt
well I think probably a lot of it was
born with the idea of kinesian economy
you know economics that in flat times
governments spend more money to help if
you like
smooth out the highs and the lows and
then they withdraw and repay that debt
in the good times but they never do
right right so the idea was to smooth
out the variability in the so-called
business cycle that's part of it I think
another and that's a good thing to do as
long as you have the discipline to start
putting money back into the system when
you're trading well the economy's strong
taxation revenues are flowing in and
that's what's what well it's awesome
it's also a good thing to do if you
presume that
you can by Fiat in some sense reduce
that kind of variability that's not
self-evident right because most systems
are that are reasonably stable have to
oscillate to some degree and you might
think it would be a good idea to flatten
out the oscillation it's a good idea
well if you can do it but the key is to
do it in the better times discipline
yourself to prepare for the next
downturn and one of the reasons that the
whole of the West and Beyond the West in
my view is in such a dangerous place
today is we haven't done that we've got
spending spending spending right so the
theories predicated on the notion that
you're going to do both but the reality
is that it's very unlikely that
governments will do more than one yeah
right and and so why have they not done
it in Australia to be fair they had been
that the previous government deserve
some credit they've done a lot of good
things they had floated the dollar
they'd started on making the place more
productive better industrial relations
Etc et cetera Etc
but they had left a rapidly building set
of deficits and a ballooning debt by
today's standards I got to tell you
compared to the sort of money that is
owed as a percentage of GDP around the
world China being a horrendous Britain
America France we saw Greece they got to
175 percent debt to GDP ratio and we saw
what that looked like a first world
country where kids went to school hungry
literally because their parents couldn't
put food in the refrigerator and there
was no longer a government program to
put it there these things can happen
Italy went very very close to the same
we should clarify for everybody that's
watching and listening the distinction
between deficit and debt and so a
deficit is overspending generally
calculated on a yearly level yeah that's
right and then the debt is the
cumulative the consequences of the
deficit yes and so to attack the deficit
then each year the government doesn't
spend more than it brings in and to pay
off the debt means that the cumulative
consequences of the deficit are also
eradicated and so your gov the
government you're involved with
demonstrated that this was possible and
so what what exactly how did you do that
like I'm very interested in the
mechanics so how did you analyze what
needed to be reduced let's say or what
revenues needed to be increased how did
you prioritize the spending and how did
you bring that economic overspending
under control without simultaneously
dooming yourself to substantive uh let's
say unpopularity uh well there was
plenty of that but let me just backtrack
a little bit and I should pay some
credit here when we first met together
the first formal meeting as a new
government having been sworn in only a
few days about a week after winning uh
the election in 1996 months 1996. we met
for the first time and the Prime
Minister who was a man of conviction
you've got to start with conviction
you've got to think these things matter
you're there to make a difference you're
not there just to satiate the latest
political fad and to smooth over
people's feelings you've got to actually
believe in something and he said we need
to recognize this is intergenerationally
unfair
and we need to start to do something
about winding back these deficits and
then after that came the issue of well
here's the opportunity not just to pay
down the debt but maybe to get rid of it
all together and then we should say the
treasurer of the day Peter Costello was
very single-minded ably backed by a
finance minister who'd been a state
Premier John Fay then we had the health
Minister we had the junior Treasurer and
me and I in theory was asked by the
prime minister to help with the economic
portfolios because I had Agriculture and
Mining in my brief so conviction
believing in something was important
in today's world we sometimes lose sight
of the judeo-christian beliefs that
built our society this is why it is so
important to study scripture and develop
a dedicated prayer life there's no
better way to do that than with hallow
hallow is the number one Christian
Prayer app in the U.S and the number one
Catholic app in the world it's filled
with studies meditations and Reflections
including the number one Christian
podcast the Bible in the ear download
Hollow today and try their Advent pray
25 challenge a 25-day journey through
Bible stories from both the Old and New
Testament leading up to the birth of
Jesus these meditations are led by cast
members from the largest Christian
streaming Series in history The Chosen
Advent pray 25 will help grow your
understanding of mankind and develop a
disciplined prayer habit during the
season when our discipline is put to the
test download Halo for three months
completely free and experience a
personal development that can come from
regular prayer meditation and reflection
on who the Bible calls us to be get
Hollow for free at hollow.com Jordan
it's hallow.com Jordan give yourself the
gift of Peace calm and discipline this
Christmas go to hollow.com com Jordan
today
the second thing I would say is that
teamwork's important because the thing
you just alluded to how do you not get
slaughtered you've got to take you know
people would speculate are they going to
do this they're going to do that they're
going to take something else away
and the minute someone had broken ranks
and said oh yeah look out you better go
out and protest on such and such an
issue it would have destroyed the
process because
people were very wary everyone agrees in
principle I was great they're going to
be economically responsible but
what happens if they fix some pain on me
right right and then this day when
governments are I'll say it less and
less coherent less and less convicted of
anything
they don't have philosophical
underpinnings they're into ad hockery
and managerialism and opportunism and
opinion pools and an opinion part and
then you combine those with
um you know a strong sense of activism
uh a a reluctance in the day of identity
politics to identify the national
interest as opposed to sexual interests
and the explosive cocktail becomes then
with social media
you know you can mount a campaign
against almost any government program
so here's a staggering thing I mean we
did that side of it then we did a major
tax reform neither were popular but we
got away with it there have been no
major reforms in this country to my way
of thinking that have involved great
difficulty and great persuasion okay so
for over 20 years so why not
so let's play Devil's Advocate why not
run the deficit
and burden the future with
today's debt
if you can thereby generate more Revenue
to help people who are in trouble
what's the what's the downside to that
well it's a very good question and it
really needs to be split into two some
government expenditures
can be reasonably described as investing
in the future and valuable for our
children and our grandchildren the
obvious ones would be high quality
education research and we know that even
if it's debt Finance very high quality
infrastructure including Communications
and so forth can help build wealth but
many other forms of government
expenditure in fact most of them are
entitlement driven
and if you let them get out of hand so
you legislate that if something
unfortunate happens to you it might be a
very desirable and compassionate thing
to do but you're entitled to X Y and Z
benefits and then you they get Mission
creep and more and more people are LED
into the net and you're spending more
and more on an entitlement basis locked
into the law of the land can only be
undone by the Parliament and the
Parliament won't play ball because the
opposition's got the numbers in the
other house or whatever then you can get
into a spiral that's really difficult
and you combine that now with the
information Age and and social media and
a lack of willingness to clearly focus
on the national interest
and it's really hard I don't make light
at all of the fact that modern
governments even though I can be
critical of their lack of philosophical
underpinnings don't do much about it in
one way because we electors we are in
danger Jordan I'm sorry to say this but
I'll give you my view in the west we are
in danger of turning our countries into
places that can't be properly governed
I know that's a tough thing to say well
and I'm not saying we're there but I'm
saying I think we're close we could we
could also point out I suppose that
the evidence that relatively
unconstrained government spending
produces inflation seems to be
incontrovertible and then we might want
to discuss exactly what inflation does
to people so inflation makes
each unit of currency purchase less
units of value too much money changing
to if you're good exactly exactly and
then you might say well who does that
punish yeah and the answer is well
inflation punishes people who've been
wise enough to yes forestall
gratification right so if you're
somebody who has been sensible and taken
the medium to long-term and account into
account and you've saved money so
accrued wealth let's say and the sort of
wealth that enables you to have a house
and an air conditioning and some
opportunities for your kids
we would generally regard that as a
social good right because we hope that
people who are not profligate and
impulsive and who put a little aside for
the future for future contingencies so
that they can take care of themselves
and others those people should be valued
and if you inflate the currency by
overspending then those are the people
who are preferentially punished because
the people who spent all their money
well they don't have any money inflation
only affects them tangentially but it
destroys the wealth of the very people
who who's careful and conscientious
striving have produced wealth to begin
with and that seems inevitable I mean
we've already seen that inflation break
out Across the Western World to quite a
remarkable degree even a degree that was
unforeseen by the central banks who
claimed that they had it under control I
don't know what inflation is running out
in Australia but I know in Canada I
think on the food fronts it's about
eight percent right now and on the
energy front in the U in the in Europe
it's far higher than that that's not all
because of government overspending but
but it's certainly contributing to that
so you punish inflation punishes exactly
the people who should be being rewarded
by taking a medium to long-term View and
it and it uh differentially benefits
people who were impulsive and profligate
in their spending and so that seems like
bad social policy as far as I can tell
so I agree with all of what you said but
I think it's really important to
understand that it's actually we've done
something worse than that because what
happened was that Australia went into
the great financial crisis I don't
really use that term internationally but
that's what we call it here the Meltdown
yeah you know Lehman Brothers yeah you
know real story about the link between
culture and good policy outcomes that
one was because I didn't break the law
but budgie they spread the spirit of
everything that was decent you know and
these are important things where's
personal responsibility where's decency
where's doing the right thing in banking
more important than making an instant
Bob but leave that aside
most countries actually were starting to
worry about their debt to GDP ratios in
the build up to the great financial
crisis they were starting to try to do
something about it take a line through
it was around 35 45 50 in a lot of
Western countries and they're saying
this is getting oh you know need to wind
it back prepare for a rainy day these
are good times they would have right to
do so then the Lehman Brothers
you know unsound money everywhere
exposed all over the place of one site
you know the system nearly collapsed at
one stage
so governments did extraordinary things
the government of America bought General
Motors
and Chrysler from memory I I don't think
they bought Ford uh governments
everywhere put bailed Banks out
insurance companies all that debt went
on to the public sector
you know private citizens suddenly I had
in theory owned General Motors call that
privatize that profit and socializing
risk yeah wow that's I'm an Australian
farmer we sometimes get accused of
wanting to do that here but but I would
push back against the charge that all
farmers are guilty of it but that's
right however what Then followed was
that government's looking at this
mountain of debt
saying what do we do now
because the discipline you asked let's
come back to how we did it
of tough decisions
there was no stomach for it Matthew
Paris wrote uh you know at the time uh
face it we're broke you know we've
overdone it we're all going to have to
live much lower living standards because
none of us have got the stomach you know
to do the hard work to wind back this
debt that's going to be so bad for our
kids we're just going to have to but
what governments did then as they looked
for inflation because inflation debate
is money and makes a debt smaller and
they look for it and they pump money
into everything we had very low interest
rates for an incredible period of time
we um we pursued endlessly quantitative
easing which is basically printing money
in a fancy way it's always ended in
tears think Bama Germany
and people kept saying where's the
inflation we want the inflation to
devalue the government debts to get it
under control so that we don't have to
[__] people with taxation
but the inflation was there it was in
asset prices right right housing prices
and who did that hurt where's the the
social impact of that
it's in housing prices especially for
young people in this country it really
really worries me
when I left school I'm a good Olive near
Jordan I might look it but I am and when
I left school in the mid 70s an average
Australian House cost four times average
annual earnings today it's 11 times and
in Sydney and Melbourne's more like 13
times now that impacts a lot of things
social cohoot I would argue it impacts
perhaps more seriously and related is
family formation in a time when 92
countries in the world have collapsing
populations and we haven't realized how
difficult that's going to be to handle
so I think uh you know it's it's it's a
very dangerous story all around and
again I say to you I actually have a lot
of sympathy for modern politicians I
could say to You've Lost Your
philosophical heart where are the great
strands of thinking through which you
used to look through to see will this
policy advance or take backwards my
dream of what the country ought to be so
I could be harsh at that level but the
other level I'd say
we've not been prepared to delay
gratification to make tough choices to
say yeah look we want to elect a
government that'll do some hard things
for our kids sake to get the whole show
back on the road
and here in this country we've had a
minerals burn we're back in debt
uh debt to GDP ratio Now is creeping out
over time it will get out to around 40
on current projections 40 is the level
at which I was European and American
country started to lose control at the
time of the GFC this stuff matters and
those interest rates rise more and more
taxpayers money's just going into
servicing the debt so it's not buying
hospitals or looking after schools or
providing reparations to countries for
climate change damage all of those
things that's all going to be debt
financed from now on and who's going to
pay that debt
men is it time to stop mindless
scrolling time to finally gain that
higher quality of life you know you're
missing out on if this sounds familiar
then on January 9th join thousands of
men all over the world to embark on a
90-day journey together in search of a
better life
it's called Exodus 90 and it was built
to help men enjoy the freedom of
becoming who they were truly made to be
Exodus 90 guides you in removing the
attachments that are holding you back
from a better life and it actually works
independent research shows that Exodus
90 men report considerable shifts after
the first 90 days including stronger
satisfaction rates in their marriages
more meaningful prayer lives and
dramatic decreases in time spent on
their phones
for the past seven years Exodus has
helped more than 60 thousand men build a
road map for living with virtue in a
culture that offers far too many paths
to self-destruction
is it time for your Exodus we start
January 9th find resources to prepare
for Exodus at exodus90.com Jordan that's
exodus90.com Jordan
so what did you do
to bring down the deficit and to pay off
the debt
that was hard and what worked well I'm
very interested in the actual mechanics
where did how did you decide where
savings could be obtained how did you do
the analysis and where were the major
savings garnered
and and how much of that was the
consequence of tax increase as well uh
no tax congression no we promise not to
okay so we kept to it I mean look there
are a few little things like airport
charges and passport levies and so forth
that we adjusted but there were no tax
increases worthy of the name we said we
wouldn't we relaxed low tax government
we're committed to that and we delivered
and the only answer really to your
question at the headline level is it was
incredibly hard work
and those five people with their helpers
I was one of them and you know I don't I
don't want to take all the credit I mean
this was the Prime Minister saying this
is what we're going to do and this is a
very capable man called Peter Costello
and a little team around him and the
rest of us working ridiculous hours
and was that his primary goal and your
primary goal was was in government yeah
we saw it as a vital part of what we
were doing no industrial relations
reform a more productive economy for me
rural recovery because it was in a very
bad way at the time that was very
important
um uh and I think it's fair to say that
we had a deep commitment to tax reform
but we're unsure about how we were going
to do it but we saw that as yeah but
getting back to what might have been
called in Britain in those days I don't
know whether they use it in Britain
anymore they talked about sound money we
thought that really mattered for a
trading Nation like Australia a
mid-sized Nation we were very deeply
committed to it but it essentially it
involved going through everything
I often tell people forgive me if
somebody's listening to me oh gosh he's
going to try to tell that story again we
spent three hours debating whether to
continue a 90 000 rat baiting program on
Lord Howe Island which is a little
island off to the coast rats got there
off a ship in the 1960s and they were
trying to eradicate them and we thought
it's not working should we continue it
or can we save 90 000 so you've got the
leaders of the country sitting around a
table spending three hours on ninety
thousand dollars
we got the bureaucrats who I gotta say
they served us well they put up the
options
but we got him to bring in a list of all
of the community groups
and many of them were gently activist in
those days they'd be wildly activists
today who were drawing on a government
teach somewhere I remember being
staggered they put this up the list on
does this this never end oh no there's
another page oh there's a page after
that and we went through that laboratory
trim here you trim that you say don't
need that group that group's just
working against the country's interests
here's another one we will support and
you know whether it's tax deductibility
or grants or whatever so why didn't the
fuhrer around that because I don't
imagine people were very thrilled about
that right because you guys didn't you
didn't I see we didn't break ranks and
neither did the broader political team
around us it was teamwork it was
conviction and teamwork they're the
things I'd want to emphasize why did the
public put up with it
well I nearly threw us out after three
years for 12 months the first budget
with some tough measures in it
was well received we went up in the
piles the second budget
when Treasury and finance and advised us
that in fact we weren't making the
progress we thought we were so we
tightened the screws a bit more and we
were in deep trouble and we nearly we
were nearly a one sir but then what
happened this is a really interesting
thing
the rewards started to flow oh look I
should just say on how we did it there
were still some assets that we felt
could be privatized that's not always a
popular idea but there were some we felt
it could be privatized and we made a
solemn commitment that selling any
family silver that was sold would go to
debt reduction not to a new kitchen if I
could put it that way we're going to pay
the house off we're not going to build a
new kitchen if you see that yeah what
I'm trying to make and and we did that
and we we stuck to it and I think there
was a slow but begrudging respect in the
Australian Community these guys you know
actually believe in something I think
conviction and belief
well in those days it carried for
something I I hope it still would uh and
so um you know we progressed through all
that only just one second turn we won it
promising to do something as tough which
was to reform the tax system and a scrap
oh messy old Arrangement and replace it
with what was called a new tax system
without its heart a GS2 your goods and
services tax and some people say oh that
was a thing that nearly did kill you all
together but actually I think my
personal view is the other way around
because we were saying we believe in
something
they just put us back and I think the
murder of the country would have been we
don't like this very much we're really
sick of it but at least they believe in
something so we'll give them a second
term
but then the fruits started to flow
unemployment started to drop real
employment started to rise for the first
time in this country for a very long
time real wages started to rise we've
got a rail going on in Australia about
how to get real wages up and the current
government they didn't tell us they were
going to do it or not here to be
political but they didn't tell us during
the campaign they were going to do it
now they have to get wages up we're
going back to an old system of
industrial relations you can graph it
out wages Rose when we engaged in
industrial relations freedoms measures
you know to free up the workplace and
let people negotiate better outcomes and
be more productive and ask more pay
that's when wages started to rise and so
by the time the next election came
around we had a sort of amazing results
and everybody loved us and it was all
turned around so
she got relatively rapid results yeah oh
yeah in ways that people could actually
detect and oh even enjoy yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
absolutely yeah I mean we we didn't
think we'd ever see employment
unemployment down at those levels again
but we got there you know the
bureaucrats were saying you know modern
economies don't get that low and we got
there
so why did it go sideways and and things
returned to their normal State of
Affairs let's say
I said I wouldn't be political let me be
honest and so I think towards the end we
were getting a little lacks and the
opposition was looking good and the
alternative prime minister was promising
to be
fiscally conservative I.E to continue
what we were doing right
and he looked like John Howard liked
John Howard's a second longer serving
prime minister a man I admire hugely and
count as a friend and people thought
it's time for a change there's a bit of
the Australian sort of give the other go
yeah yeah well there's something to be
said for that there is something to be
said no I'm not knocking it no no well
one of the reasons that democracies work
I think is because
you constantly replace people at the top
and and and so your point is that but
not too constantly we've got to live in
there long enough to get there see it
took us three years I mean we did all
our hard work but it took us three years
I think if I look it back
um as a government of conviction because
it was a people a group of people made
up they'd been in opposition for quite a
while
we were convicted and we were committed
to working as a team and to trying to do
something having relievers of power
wasn't just about keeping them and
people say oh you know John you're just
a politician you all say that but it was
true of us there were enough of us who
believed in the country and in my case
not particularly addicted to Politics as
such was a means to an end you know I
believed in these things I'd had my
father had almost lost his life fighting
during the second world war and I
thought well I I don't have a waterfire
thank God
but I can try and make a contribution
here and if it's a bit painful well it's
not like losing a life is it lying on a
hospital bed for 18 months so great uh
shot to pieces and spending the rest of
your life covered in scars and with bits
of lead coming to your shoulder and
stomachs that don't work and that's what
he had to put up with right so you know
a little bit of Courage doesn't hurt
sometimes have a go yeah well I I did a
podcast with Benjamin Netanyahu here
recently and he talked about
the price they paid in Israel for his
government's economic reforms and they
tried to
well their their actions were analogous
in some sense to yours he was more
concerned with cutting cutting tax rates
and transforming the environment away
from the hypothetically socialist
Paradise that Israel had degenerated
into and
they paid a big price for that
electorally but the medium to long-term
consequences for the country seemed I
would say seem to have been spectacular
and of course now he's back he's back in
charge of the country or will be soon
and he seemed also to be somebody who
was driven
fundamentally by principle rather than
by
what would you say a desire for the
trappings of popularity and power
keeping your hands on the cycle of the
levers well yeah well I think I think a
lot of the politicians that I've watched
and talked to when they don't rule by
principle let's say or when they're not
governed by principal themselves they
devolve to short-term opinion poll
manipulating and they deliver people
what they hypothetically want in the
short term even though it's very hard to
measure what people truly want and you
can't do that very accurately with
opinion polls and now you can't no no
you because you don't give them choices
you can't set the choices out clearly
enough no no it's very hard first of all
in some really comprehensive sense
people
want many contradictory things
simultaneously yeah and so scatter shot
asking them about what they want today
in a very narrow manner doesn't inform
you about their true wishes that's a
very difficult thing to learn how to do
it yeah you know would you like a 10 pay
rise well yes we're all for that right
but if it means that you're going to
have to repay it because it's borrowed
money is going to cost you 12 well no
maybe I don't want right right exactly
this is the problem you get you can't
present them with the with the real cost
and and the implications of the
decisions that they make very important
just to go back to the issue though
um we got
and by the grace of God reasonably quick
results and people could see the
benefits of better governance and in the
end maybe we got a bit tired
um that they felt that there was an
alternative that would be safe hands and
perhaps perhaps a little bit less edgy
than we'd been in saying you know
perhaps we sounded a bit like we were so
harsh little and maybe sometimes even a
little bit self-righteous look what
we've done I don't I don't maybe that
was the way some Australians saw it at
the time but here's the point it
unraveled very quickly because the GFC
hit
and um the saying in Australian was go
hard go early go households we pump the
whole heap of money
uh out there to try and counter the GFC
in my view far too much for too long
and some would say well that's that was
the voice of reason and experience I'd
say that talking others might say oh
Anderson you just did a tight Scot right
I thought it was two months and and then
you know so we started to build up the
debt again and then we had covered and
now we've got climate policy which in my
view is often being ill-advised and not
subject to rigorous economic analysis
and environmental analysis for the real
impact that those policies will have and
here's one point that I would I would
challenge people to really
you know correct me on but I think I'm
right right through all the tendency and
policy terms
has been to produce results that
discriminate against younger people that
make it harder for them to improve their
real wages and harder for them to get
their foot on to the asset uh louder
unless unless well how much do you think
that that's driven in some sense
consciously and explicitly by something
approximating an anti-growth ethos I
mean my my understanding is that
the more radical voices on the climate
amelioration front
presume that it's simply impossible for
upcoming generations of people in the
west and certainly people in the
developing world to Aspire to anything
even approximating the standard of
living that we currently enjoy and that
they should bloody well get used to
having less and the sooner the better
and so the fact that young people are
being priced out of the housing market
let's say and
and face a more uncertain economic
future in some ways looks to me like a
feature not a bug it's something that's
actually part of the plan because if
you're if your Viewpoint is
fundamentally male enthusian you think
well human beings will multiply until
there's far too many of us and there'll
be a catastrophe as a consequence which
is pretty simple-minded biological
modeling by the way then you're going to
assume that everything has to be
oriented towards placing
extremely severe constraints on growth
and if that means impoverishing people
now while you're forestalling some
hypothetical future catastrophe and
that's entirely justifiable and it seems
to me we're running down that road as
fast as we possibly can you know with
moral flag firmly in air saying to young
people and the developing World well you
know we had it pretty good but we
probably burnt out more than we should
have and I think it's time for you guys
to pay and so and like I don't buy any
of that because I don't think the limits
to growth model is biologically
appropriate appropriate in the least
because human beings aren't yeast in a
Petri dish by any stretch of the
imagination and I think that the idea
that we need to impoverish the poor and
the young to save the planet will not
only is not only morally reprehensible
and arrogant but will also produce a far
worse planet on the environmental front
I mean I think all the data suggests
that and so I don't exactly understand
why people are buying into this with
such avidity because there's no evidence
whatsoever that is producing the results
that are intended even by the people who
are pushing forward the policies
Black Rifle coffee company is helping
you knock out your holiday shopping with
a ton of awesome new products this year
shop the best Brewing gear thermosis
mugs and apparel designed for folks who
love country and coffee Black Rifle
sources the most exotic roast from
around the globe all coffee is roasted
here in the U.S by veteran-led teams of
coffee experts stuff your Christmas
stockings with the latest roasts from
America's coffee for 10 off with the
code Jordan better yet sign your Secret
Santa up for a coffee Club subscription
imagine the joy of a pre-scheduled
coffee delivery your favorite roast when
you need them most it's the gift that
keeps on giving Black Rifle coffee
company is veteran founded and operated
they take pride in serving coffee and
culture to people who love America every
purchase you make with Black Rifle helps
support veteran and first responder
causes go to blackriflecoffee.com and
use promo code Jordan for 10 off coffee
Coffee Gear apparel and when you sign up
for a new coffee Club subscription
that's black riflecoffee.com with promo
code Jordan for 10 off Black Rifle
coffee supporting veterans and America's
coffee
a lot of issues in there let me have a
little bit of go let me have a little
bit of a go I think I think you're right
the the our parliaments now are infused
with a lot of people who think we've got
to stop growth and wind it back but they
won't tell you that so I decided to say
to me a couple years ago
uh when I I said you know we've got to
be really careful on climate change
policy if we frighten the living data
outside of our kids so they're all so
depressed as we tell they are because I
think there's no future rather than
saying well here's a challenge let's go
out and try and solve it we've solved
other challenges we can solve this one
they've become very defeatist and now we
get stories all the time about young men
having vasectomies because they didn't
want to bring children into this
terrible world and the scientists said
to me ah well it's because that
governments are not taking effective
control over uh climate and that's
what's depressing the children so I went
to Australia's the Buckeye respect most
a fellow called mccrindle in this
country he has a research outfit and I
asked him I said this anxiety amongst
our young people's record numbers of
kids expressing uh
anxiety are because of climate change I
think the world's going to end he said
no it's much more complicated than that
the kids are smart they're working out
there's going to be really hard for them
to get a job they're working now there's
going to be really hard for them to
afford a home they're working out that
that probably means they're going to
have to live at home and not go and fly
they're working out the romance is very
difficult they're worried about climate
but there's a whole heap of things so
there you have it so you couldn't
possibly confess your policies were
going to make it even harder for young
people so this is at the heart in my
view of a lot of the problem we now have
I alluded to it briefly traditionally in
Australia we've had three broad
philosophical political streams
conservatism nothing left to conserve so
they haven't got much to say the classic
liberals believed in small government in
free enterprise strong civil societies
well now they look to government for
everything it seems and the social
Democrats are sort of left of center
types many of whom look they were pretty
noble their objectives at least were
Noble last time I said that was
particularly true of the union leader
types and the people who were really
working for the working class many of
them were people who just wanted the
weak and the oppressed and the mods and
lives to be recognized as members of the
community as you know part of the family
Australia that's Noble I disagree with
what they wanted to do we used to have
these arguments in the parliament people
had views and they assessed the issues
of the day you know they looked through
the lens of ish you know to to the what
they thought Australia should look like
but now there's a fourth which is this
um
inversion of our traditional belief
system so that now the problem is that
Mother Earth is God we're the enemy of
Gaya we're the ones who have offended
and we must atone by
maybe we've got to reduce our living
standards or at its extremes
you think Club of Rome in the 60s we're
all going to die there's too many of us
if you really press some of them it
boils down to life about ethics you know
we're sinking the planet the lifeblood
is going to go down so we've got to so
anything is Justified we've got a
jettison some yeah now would you rather
be the person Jordan who was jettisoned
drowned or the person who made the
decision that somebody else was going to
yeah well that's a right precisely yeah
well he's just a one little question I
would make out of that I do see some
very very very very privileged people
who are climate change activists who
don't seem to intend themselves to make
any sacrifices it's not going to go
overboard they think someone else should
and I'm really worried that the Young
and the less well-off in our society
well we already know who's going to go
overboard because they're already
starting to go overboard I mean what
happens inevitably is that if you if
you're the policies you're pursuing to
save the planet which which by the way
have been highly ineffective even by the
metrics of the people who are attempting
such things
if you're the consequence of your
policies is to radically increase the
price and decrease the reliability of
energy provision
then what you do is you tip
the hundreds of millions of people who
are already living at a near subsistence
level maybe we have just started to
clamber somewhat above that you tip all
of them back into
insufficient subsistence living and so
you definitely by making energy more
expensive there's absolutely 100 percent
no doubt that the primary effect is the
impoverishment the further
impoverishment of the already poor and
so they're going to be the sacrificial
victims on this front and that would be
true in part in the west because the
poorest Western people will definitely
pay the biggest price for higher energy
costs but it's even more true in the
developing world because as poor as poor
people are in the west they're richer
than poor people in the developing world
and if energy is more scarce and food is
also more expensive than the poor people
in the poorest places will be the ones
who suffer the most and that's there's
absolutely no doubt that that's already
happening and so it's a very it's a very
peculiar thing to see especially when
it's conjoined with the fact that I
don't see any evidence whatsoever and
I've talked to people who are very
knowledgeable on this front people like
Bjorn lomberg for example who've
reviewed the evidence very carefully and
showed that all of the tremendous amount
of money that we've already spent wasted
let's say on such things as hypothetical
climate amelioration have not only not
Amelia curated climate alteration in the
least not measurably but have definitely
made energy far more expensive and in
places like Germany have also made it
dirtier so I read the other day that I
think Germany has fallen to 170th I hope
I have this stat right but the principle
of it's right anyways is that
energy is not only way more expensive
and way more unreliable in Germany to
the point where for example
manufacturers of car batteries for
electric cars can no longer do it
profitably in Germany because
electricity costs are too high but that
well they've demolished the energy
provision system and rendered themselves
hyper reliant on the Russians they've
also made their energy per kilowatt much
dirtier because you need backup for
these hypothetically green Renewables
which aren't green At All by the way you
need backup and that backup has to be
fossil fuel and they've shut off their
nuclear plants and so now they're
turning to Coal or many of the of the
Europeans are now turning to wood
burning to prepare for the winter and
they're deforesting in many places
they're deforesting the the country and
so one of the things we've got to get
real straight here is that even if
you're
goal and even if you have the goal of
a more sustainable environment and you
have your metrics in place to produce
that and even if you accept the
apocalyptic version of carbon dioxide
over production which I don't at all by
the way but even if you do
there's no evidence whatsoever that
these counterproductive policies that
are punitive in relationship to the poor
have had any impact on the environment
at all that hasn't been entirely
negative and so I don't see at all how
anybody on the radical left on the
globalist utopian environmental front
can put forward an argument saying that
there's anything about that that's moral
because we have way more people who are
poor than we needed to have we're
impoverishing people in the west and the
developing world and while we're doing
that we're actually making the
environment worse by by the standards
that the people who put in the policies
regard as the appropriate standards so
how is that
helpful and then on the colonial front
you know one of the things we hear all
the time is how awful the the European
world really has been in terms of its
imposition of colonial uh
of the colonial Empire on the rest of
the world and there's no doubt that you
know all of us walk on blood-soaked
ground and that's part of the
catastrophe of Being Human I suppose but
I can't see anything more Colonial that
we've ever done than to insist that
we enjoyed a pretty damn good standard
of living and that was driven almost
entirely by fossil fuel Reliance but
it's pretty not much
enough of that for everyone else and we
cannot expect to have a world where
those in the developing world could
aspire to or hope to have anything like
the prosperity that we've enjoyed and
we're going to be the good examples in
our own country and teach those let's
say backward Savages exactly how they
should treat the planet I don't see I
can't see anything more Colonial than
that attitude like I see in Canada for
example I think I read recently that
if Canada hits all of its climate goals
for the next 25 years
we will reduce our carbon output less
than China will increase its carbon
output next year
so it's completely bloody pointless from
any practical perspective and the
argument might be well we should lead by
example it's like now should we we think
those
developing people in the developing
countries who are trying to move towards
some reasonable standard are too damn
dumb to figure this out all by
themselves eh and we're going to charge
in there like to save you and while
we're doing that we're going to
impoverish them and we're going to make
our own countries worse off and there's
nothing Colonial about that it's like I
don't think so I think there's something
plenty Colonial built out we should say
it's no wonder that you'd like to have
enough food to eat and not have to burn
dung and wood in your huts and it's no
wonder that you'd like to have some
educational opportunities to your
children and obviously the way forward
to that is going to involve fossil fuel
utilization clearly because there's no
alternative and we'll just get the hell
out of the way while you pursue
quite successfully by the way what we've
been pursuing for 200 years I don't see
a moral I don't see a moral leg to stand
on in that in that debate it's appalling
and it's murderous it's worse than
appalling it's murderous have you
noticed all of these big tech companies
masquerading as privacy companies every
now and again Google Apple or Facebook
will release a security feature in an
attempt to convince you that they're not
actually collecting and selling off your
data this is not true free big Tech
platforms make their money by selling
your information to advertisers they
know when you're online what kind of
content you're engaging with and even
the transactions you're making to
protect myself against big Tech's prying
eyes I use expressvpn when you use the
expressvpn app on your computer or phone
you're hiding your unique IP address
that means that websites can't find your
real location or track what you do
online in addition expressvpn encrypts
and reroutes 100 of your online activity
which means hackers can't see it plus
expressvpn is incredibly easy to use all
you have to do is tap one button to
protect all your devices one expressvpn
subscription covers up to five devices
at the same time so you can protect your
entire family too expressvpn is rated
number one by CNET wired tech radar and
countless others protect your online
activity today with the VPN rated number
one by Business Insider go to
expressvpn.com Jordan and get an extra
three months free on a one-year package
that's expressvpn.com Jordan
expressvpn.com Jordan to learn more
so will they pick up some of those those
themes I mean I'm as you're not involved
in agriculture
and I'm passionate about feeding people
and you made the comment about driving
people in the developing world into
poverty I put a slightly different Twist
on it you'd reverse Decades of the most
astounding progress in lifting people
out of poverty right
uh strata is one of the seven big
hitters in international agricultural
research so six countries and the Gates
Foundation that put money into it and
we've just done some research which is
really interesting it shows that
participants benefit their own
agricultural sectors enormously because
while we participate and help the third
world developing world with their
feeding issues and so forth we learn
things that we're able to bring back
here it's a real win-win and the
progress has been amazing an extra five
billion people fed properly right right
it's stunning over the last 50 years
that's something to celebrate that's for
sure and that's a huge a huge part of
that as a consequence if they're turning
to something like free market Solutions
Western know-how under a western
rules-based system led by the Dreadful
Americans
I mean pity help us of the Americans are
not oversighted are you worried about
climate change and environmentalism the
two greatest threats are to return big
slabs of the world's population to
grinding poverty so that they're not
able to afford the luxury of wondering
about how the environment might be
faring because they can't feed their
kids
and the other will be the breaking of
the rules-based system that the Allies
basically put in place in 1945 and
people will laugh at me for saying that
but it's true and every Western country
is worried about supply chain security
after covert well that was globalization
and it was the Americans making certain
that the trade routes were kept open all
right we've got to retreat a little bit
but the answer is not to go back
to some system where we break that
rules-based system and the reason is
very simple the autocrats of this world
don't give a damn about environmentalism
it writes a very distant priority behind
their own power we know that
you can see that in Beijing today what
matters to them is power so if you're
worried about environmentalism Don't
Starve people and don't break the
Western liberal rules-based system that
we've imposed in police you know and we
you know beat the Soviets and all of
those sorts of things and now we're
putting it on the limits to growth model
too has a certain type of deep pathology
associated with it that needs to be
brought to the surface too because one
hypothesis is you know the planet has a
limited carrying capacity and it's a
zero-sum game and we're malthusian uh
you know routes and overpopulating the
place and that what we need to do in
consequence is limit growth and perhaps
move towards a much less populated
planet that last one is a very
frightening proposition because as you
said a lot about ethics well who gets to
go you know that's the real question and
exactly how and who are the monsters who
make the decision well exactly exactly
that but I I also think that that
model it's certainly not the only model
that you can derive from the data let's
say because one of the things I learned
when I was deeply investigating the
relationship between economic growth and
long-term environmental viability let's
say sustainability something like that
was that
strangely enough
and perhaps not so if you make people if
you can lift people out of absolute
poverty and get them up to something
approximating five thousand dollars a
year in terms of of average say
contribution to GDP then they stop
adopting a short-term View and they
start to adopt a long-term view because
they have the luxury of being able to
think beyond the moment and I suppose
partly why we want security which is
what wealth can offer at least to some
degree is so that we can we're not bound
by the absolute emergencies of the
moment absolutely they can stretch our
minds across a longer Spanish well and
so if you make little impact on family
formation as well right right right well
one of the things you see is that as
soon as you educate women that family
size tends to fall and and if that
accuse the women of being dumb I I hate
the way we do that women in the
developing world are not stupid well how
can we be beside patronizing if you get
them to a point where they think their
children are going to survive they're
going to get an education deal you know
and what have you they will do what
everybody else has done and control the
size of their families actually they
might overshoot because of what's being
missed 92 countries in the world today
have declining populations 92 there's
only 190 countries in the world half of
them are in Decline some demographers
believe China might go from 1.4 billion
to five or six hundred million by the
end of the century right right on child
policy they're not having children the
surfing of boys not enough girls that's
a horror story in itself yeah and you're
going to have massive loneliness and a
terrible burden on young people trying
to support the old people so you're
going to overshoot the possibility but
the real Point here is your point it's a
really relevant right lift those people
out of poverty give them a perspective
where they can make wise decisions and
what have you and that issue and then we
can talk it's only the Middle East and
and America and Africa and Nigeria
countries like that that look like
they're going to keep building
populations for the next few decades
other parts of the world it's stabilized
all coming down well we could talk about
a high immigration policy here because
the government's worried about our low
birth rate in Australia
well we can also talk about the perhaps
what some of the preconditions for that
wealth generation are so first of all we
could point out that
if you get people up to about five
thousand dollars per year in terms of
their ability to generate income then
they start to be concerned about the
environment but the environmental
concerns start to be expressed in a way
that's I would say
truly sustainable because you can
imagine that we could take a top-down uh
approach to environmental planning but
top-down Solutions have the problem of
first of all being unitary and second of
all so they can go catastrophically
wrong if they're wrong they're also
difficult to impose but if you make
enough people if you free enough people
from absolute poverty they start to be
concerned about environmental
maintenance locally and so the what we
get is a distribute attempt across the
world of people to improve the quality
of their local environment so that's
maybe hundreds of millions of people
that have a longer term Viewpoint
instead of a few centralist utopians
trying to govern the whole planet and
that's a much more stable solution so we
should be doing everything we can to
lift the world's absolute poor out of
their absolute poverty and we do that so
then we can say well how do we do that
and one of the ways we do that is by
um
moving towards the provision of free and
ample energy that's a crucial issue
that's how we fed five billion extra
people right over the last 25 years and
so that means we have to give some
serious consideration to intelligent use
of fossil fuels which we're doing
anyways exceptions we're using too many
we are we're hopelessly addicted to
fossil fuels and there are many
downsides and precautionary principles
we should pursue Technologies and so
forth that will lower our Reliance that
help us absorb all carbon that's a good
thing for farms in our soils I am I I
wouldn't want to be misunderstood of
saying we should stop technology or what
have you but here's the rub it's the
point that you're making
if we're going to pursue policies which
drive people back into poverty
we will defeat ourselves unbelievably
and no one's paying enough attention to
it we lift them out of poverty with
available and affordable energy and if
we break that we will drive them back
into it it's your point yes
we won't save the planet that's right
that's because of badly designed
policies driven by I hate to say this by
the fact we've become so emotive so I
was staggered to discover that if you go
out and do a poll in Australia it's been
done
um and ask Australians what is our
contribution to Global emissions
fifty percent of people say it's
somewhere between 10 and 20 percent it's
one percent and so here's the rub I'm a
farmer okay well I
I work on a farm now my son and
daughter-in-law as you know uh run run
the business and they do a terrific job
and they are looking for ways everywhere
to be better environmental stewards and
to absorb more carbon pull it out of the
air good we happen to meet on that one
that's good that's a good thing to do
and Farmers recycle cycle and recycle
carbon so you've only got to absorb a
little bit more and if people are
worried about carbon in the air there's
part of the solution but but um
uh here is the point that we've got to
do this in ways which continues the
upward March in lifting people out of
deprivation of poverty the Improvement
we don't realize how well we've done not
just in lifting people out of poverty by
improving their nutrition education with
the exception of a few cultures now even
the girls around the world are getting
much better education we thought
most people have much better access to
electricity than has been thought that
we've we've fallen behind in our
understanding of the progress we've made
now it's been so rapid it's hard to
believe and to stop it ill I think we
should take great pride in them and
we've done it with research with
extension compassion concern for others
that's not a bad thing to have well
we've also done it we've also done it
and it's free marketing well that's okay
so we can turn to that so not only
so we know that we've made tremendous
progress on the economic front
especially since the the fall of the
Soviet Union and it's part of the last
10 years he's a little effect to it I'm
told and by people I believe I've made a
lot of people in this area the world's
Farmers have produced enough food in
each of the last 10 years for 10 billion
people that's well in excessive global
population
and I don't think we're straining our
ecosystems to do it to be honest
um using more fertilizer perhaps than I
would like and that's a story in itself
but of course that's made out of gas
it's one of the great emitters and all
of that things that people are worried
about but Germany is a a country where a
lot of gas is turned you know used to
make ammonia
half the world's grain production
depends on that the artificial
fertilizers are made out of it on fossil
fuel and BASF as I understand it in
Germany one of the biggest producers in
the western world is moving their
operations to China and we talk supply
chain security
yeah it's going to move I think that as
a farmer that I'll be blunt about it I'm
worried about that yeah I'm worried
about that
um and anyway we have made the solid
progress that we're in danger of
reversing because we don't know what
we're doing and here's the other point I
wanted to make sorry as a farmer one
thing I know is that it doesn't matter
what we do in Australia our chief
scientists know this confirmed this in
Senate hearings only a little while ago
when we talk about floods and fires and
damage through it doesn't matter what
Australia does so as a farmer
whatever is going to happen globally is
not going to be influenced by Australia
I have to prepare my family have to
prepare to farm
in whatever circumstances come what's
the point
at a practical level for politicians to
say we're doing the things that will
save you the next flood or the next fire
or whatever in this country is just
dishonest it's not going to make any
difference we know that there's no
evidence that any of the things we've
done so far have made any difference but
the whole even of the whole globe did it
maybe we don't know what the outcome
would be it doesn't matter well one of
the things that with regards to carbon
dioxide output one of the things that
people are listening and watching might
want to think about is
you know I've been attacked many times
for being a climate change denier let's
say and I don't really care for that
accusation one way or another but one of
the things I've I know recently from my
investigations is that
one of the consequences of carbon
dioxide overproduction over the last 15
years because carbon dioxide levels have
been going up and some of that seems to
be a consequence of anthropogenic
activity human industrial activity let's
say is that
paradoxically and contrary to all
predictions on the environmentalist side
the planet is now 15 percent greener
than it was in the year 2000 and 15
percent is a that's a tremendous amount
it's an area that's larger than the
United States and and it isn't obvious
to me that that's a bad thing and it's
more than that
the the most
remarkable greeting has occurred in
semi-arid areas and so the deserts are
supposed to expand as the globe was
Globe warmed or the climate changed
because that was a you know fate
accompli in terms of terminological
transformation and what's happening
instead is that the green that plants
have invaded the semi-arid areas to a
large degree and the reason for that is
because
plants have to breathe through pores and
if they open their pores to get more
carbon dioxide because carbon dioxide is
levels are relatively low let's say
they let water evaporate out of these
pores
if there's more carbon dioxide they can
close their pores and then it turns that
out that they can grow where it's drier
and that's driven not only an expansion
of Greening everywhere there already
were plants but the proliferation of
plants into areas that couldn't support
them before and so that it's very hard
for me to look at that because that's a
huge change 15 and not think well maybe
more plants is a good thing
and then but there's an additional
feature that's going along with that
that also has to be contended with and I
don't see people on the environmental
front
grappling with these issues in any
manner that strikes me as credible
not only have
has the total biomass of plants
increased tremendously 15 but
crop yields have gone up
because it turns out that carbon dioxide
is a pretty damn good fertilizer so
instead of having less food because of
climate change forced by carbon dioxide
we actually have more food and we have
more food with less fertilizer and so I
think you could make a case and I know
this is utterly heretical and it might
not even be true that carbon dioxide
outputs are napped good and I also know
for example that
we have somewhere between 300 and 400
parts per million of carbon dioxide in
the atmosphere right now and that's
actually a historical it's actually Low
by historical standards quite low and
plants really have a hard time even
living at 150. so that's the cutoff for
plant for Ability for plants to breathe
and so a carbon dioxide intensive world
is actually a lot more friendly to
plants now you could say well we're
still risking catastrophe by changing
the biosphere that rapidly because of 15
increase in plant coverages nothing
trivial it there may be elements of that
that are destabilizing in some ways I
don't understand but the prediction that
we were going to produce an expansion of
desert for example
and a denuding of of of a transformation
of semi-arid areas into desert that all
seems to be like completely wrong it
just that did not happen the opposite
happened and so I don't know what to
make of that fact because as far as I
can tell that fact is incontrovertibly
true
and so I don't see there's a lake a lake
for the for the apocalyptic
environmentalists to stand on especially
given that their policies have been
counterproductive and they're driving
people into poverty so
different question now that's it yeah
just a brief encapsulation yeah I think
I'd make a few comments I'm not a
scientist I would only say I don't think
the science has ever settled I don't buy
that line because science always moves
it should always be questioning for more
knowledge more information
um but so I will assume that the science
broadly tells us that things are
changing and a 15 increase is
extraordinary rapid change in yourself
yeah so I expect volatility but there's
a couple of really important points to
make out of this
if
democratically people want to address
this issue that is their right but
secondly it must do so on an informed
basis and you must look for high quality
policy and you won't get that without a
good debate so we've been talking about
some of the things here that really
matter there's a trade-off to be made if
you go too far with these things and if
you ask me to make a trade between
saving the planet tonight on a on a whim
and feeding people I'm sorry I'm going
with feeding people
while educating them too that's that's a
moral choice you know and I'm going with
feeding people if you were to say to me
do I think we should be looking for new
technologies for reducing agriculture's
Reliance on on fossil fuels and
artificial fertilizers as it happens yes
I do but I don't think we ought to be
doing it in a way that sacrifices
production and feeding people that's
that's what I'm saying and and so it
comes back we were talking earlier about
budget deficits and what have you
you've got to have conviction you've got
to be guided by the data you've got to
actually think facts matter taking
people with you matters well you also
talked about the necessity of being
Guided by principles and so one of the
things we can talk about too is if we
accepted the proposition that it would
be good to develop policies that would
ameliorate absolute poverty and that
that would be good for poor people and
that would be good for the planet too
we've done a lot of it well we might
also ask how we've done it because I
would say that it's clearly the case
that in places like communist China
let's say which has gone undergone this
economic Revolution that the degree to
which that economic Revolution was
possible was because even the Chinese
Communists accepted the Necessities the
necessity of some of the principles that
go along with open and free markets open
and free trade and so one of those would
be so the West is getting a pretty rough
time now on the radical front and this
is feeding into ideas like we owe the
third world reparations for our climate
damage for being Colonial and oppressive
and that are the ethos that's associated
with the West is fundamentally Colonial
and oppressive in nature and the thing
that really bothers me about that is
that I believe that the fundamental
positive spirit that has imbued the West
which is actually not a western creation
because it's actually a middle eastern
creation the fundamental spirit that has
imbued the West is the only spirit that
has ever actually lifted people who were
oppressed out of their oppression yeah
and so what that means is this
radical critique that's been aimed at
Western culture in the name of freedom
for oppression is actually attacking the
very spirit that has lifted people out
of Oppression to the degree that that's
been the case I'm sure you're right well
we could start with so what what are the
Bedrock assumptions of Western culture
that make such things as free trade
possible assuming that that generates a
sort of generous wealth which seems to
be the case and one of them is that
there's an idea and the West hasn't been
what would you say without sin and
applying this idea that every single
person is a local a locus of implicit
Divine worth regardless of their
particularities it's a very weird
proposition right because we differ so
much in our obviously admirable
attributes some of us are more
intelligent more attractive more
powerful have more physical prowess
um are are more ethical or more
hard-working like there's endless
dimensions on which you can rank order
human beings but there's this strange
proposition that emerged essentially in
the Middle East that despite all that
surface variability and that
hierarchical rank ordering every single
person man and woman alike regardless of
race or Creed or color has to be treated
as a locus of divine worth and I don't
think that you can even make a credible
argument against slavery on moral
grounds without accepting that as an
axiomatic presumption and so then I
think well if that's the case because
look if there's no intrinsic worth
that's Divine in some sense so sacred
then why can't I just do with you what I
want if I have the power because why is
that wrong exactly like it might be
inconvenient for you and you are no
doubt going to be motivated to Rebel
maybe if you don't want to succumb but
perhaps you'd be motivated to Rebel but
I don't see how you can make a moral
case that if I can do it I shouldn't if
you're going to make the moral case you
have to make the assumption that
each person in some sense is created in
the image of what is sacred and you
can't violate that regardless of
apparent evidence for hierarchical
difference and so it's that Spirit as
far as I can tell we were talking about
William Wilberforce just before the
podcast started and the British attempt
to Ebola slavery which is the real
Miracle right yeah not that they were
ever involved in slavery because that
was true everywhere for all times every
bar including black Empires right right
well well and it was it was part of the
alternative hypothesis that something
like might meant moral virtue and might
inspired moral virtue meant right and
that was the ethos that governed
everyone everywhere until this strange
idea emerged that regardless of
appearance somehow each person was
characterized by intrinsic and violable
worth and so then you see the radicals
go after that in the name of the poor
and oppressed and I think wait a minute
guys like you're failing to understand
something here which is that the spirit
that emerged to push back against
slavery
is the central Spirit of the very system
that you're trying to demolish so how in
the world is that going to work out for
the people you purport to stand for
practically I mean it's definitely the
case that the distribution of the
biblical Corpus throughout Europe
to begin with was part and parcel of the
process that indicated to the oppressed
peasantry of Europe that
there was something fundamentally wrong
with
with with serfdom for example that it
was it was a violation of something like
a divine order and that all happened
that happened a large consequence
because
of the Gutenberg Bible and the
distribution of the biblical Corpus far
and wide which also helped people become
literate and to also start to understand
that no one had the right to oppress
them we can go into that issue of like
inviolable individual worth but I don't
see how that idea can be challenged on
historical grounds because as far as I
can tell that's what happened it's those
ideas strange ideas that led to the
abolition of slavery we could talk about
Britain you know a fair bit about
Wilberforce why don't we talk a little
bit about what he did because it's quite
the bloody miracle
we will be right back with our
conversation with John Anderson first we
wanted to give you a sneak peek at
Jordan's new series Exodus
so the Hebrews created history as we
know it
don't get away with anything and so you
might think you can bend the fabric of
reality and that you can treat people
instrumentally and that you can bow to
the Tyrant and violate your conscience
without cost you will pay the piper it's
going to call you out of that slavery
into Freedom even if that pulls you into
the desert
and we're going to see that there's
something else going on here that is far
more Cosmic and deeper than what you can
imagine the highest
Spirit to which we're beholden is
presented precisely as that spirit that
allies itself with the cause of Freedom
against tyranny I want villains to get
punished but do you want the villains to
learn before they have to pay the
ultimate price that's such a Christian
question
well I I thank you for asking it does
before I do
um to take up this point that
that you're alluding to Australia's
longer serving prime minister and
probably the the deepest intellectual
leader certainly since the Second World
War
I'm not the only one but in a very deep
thinker he was not a religious man but
he had a religious tradition in his
education I suppose you'd say and he
said that democracy is not so much a
machine as a spirit in which despite our
different abilities and our different
positions in society we all have a
responsibility to acknowledge that All
Souls are equal in the eyes of Heaven
that's where that idea comes from so a
higher authority is saying you know you
and I might disagree but I can't laud it
over you because somebody else is you're
just right even if I have the ability to
yeah that's right and what we're now
reduced to I think it's really important
to understand this you hear this
bleeding that oh yes we've got to
recognize that everybody's important
everybody has dignity and worth well on
what basis which is your question if
you'd strip out this uh out there of the
godhead of a higher authority on what
basis because he you run into trouble
straight away the the the most common
reason now given would be to say well
human beings have either High
Intelligence or they are they have a
sense of morality or both both arguments
are used usually together therefore
they're unique therefore they're special
but the problem you've just alluded to
the problem some are brighter some are
less bright some are stupid some are
wise some behave well some don't so
immediately you're in trouble because
you can't say they all matter equally
you've lost a model so the Wilberforce
one is example if it's in the context of
black lives matters I thought about this
a lot because I abore racism I think
it's the most appalling Doctrine because
I'm deeply imbued with a Christian view
that whether I like somebody else or not
is irrelevant
uh somebody else says they matter as
much as me you know the constituent who
attacked me on the back streets of my
and it happened a few times sometimes on
racial grounds you know where I was
attacked for my race and I had to stop
and say don't respond in kind this
person matters just as as much as I do I
might be the Deputy Prime Minister of
the country but Ohio authorities just as
worried about him in places just as much
value on him and his life as he does on
mine and that's genuinely where I happen
to come from but now okay so every
Empire we know of has kept slaves and
there are 45 million estimated slaves
today so it hasn't gone away but
only one Empire having kept slaves then
moved from within to abolish it and so
very Empire we seem to most want to hate
most now of all it's the British Empire
and so you had
this evil slave trade known as the
triangle ships would go out to the west
coast of Africa they would buy slaves
who'd been rounded up by Africans
themselves they'd gone into the Inland
slaughtered the weak and the infirm
pre-brutal stuff and the infants and
what have you marched the able-bodied
ones that could be sold for a few
trinkets back to the coast they're sold
to people in this reprehensible trade
taken to the East Indies the the way
they were packed into the ships so it
was just
absolutely in your mind mind-boggling
the inhumane and you know there were
times when they were thrown overboard so
that they could just alive to drown
so the chip owners could and trade the
same slave Traders wanted to pick up on
the insurance and what a waiter
yeah the the depravity that we're
capable of slipping into and then they'd
sail home with cargo or whatever from
them right well we need to point out
that that's par for the course right
that's just straight historical reality
that was also the case with the Roman
Empire and with the Greeks and you can
trace slavery back as far as you want
every Empire right right so this is this
is the classic Human Condition and
that's the condition in some sense of
Might makes right so so so what happens
in Britain
uh you know after the Protestant
Reformation no no he had predated that
to be fair
Rome was pretty good on calling it out
too they just never had it although they
often had power they didn't seem to have
much power in that area particularly in
terms of what some of the European
countries did in South America
but in Britain you had the rise of a
deeply uneasy conscience about this you
had a slave trader himself called Newton
who wrote Amazing Grace the famous hymn
uh he was engaged in the slave trade at
one stage he was himself enslaved by a
black African Queen and made to be a
slave to her slaves
this is not a one-way Street
and along a newton is influential in the
life of William Wilberforce and William
Wilberforce
uh whose unbelievably privileged he
inherits a fortune four or five hundred
million in a day's money he's seen as uh
you know a young
gadfly really he goes to Oxford does no
work just entertains everybody because
he can sing and he's got money so he's
always got a pie in his office for the
others to enjoy and they booze their way
alive uh you know it was pretty rough
stuff he goes to London and with Pitt
the youngest elected to Parliament at
very early age they become friends he's
seen as the future Prime Minister he
goes off on a tour of Europe with the
most brilliant mathematician and Via a
man called Isaac Milner and as they're
going along and he's tiny and Milner's
huge and the buggies right over on an
angle they're deep in philosophical
conversation and
Wilberforce decides that he actually
thinks Christianity is true so he goes
back to England says I've got to leave a
parliament that's a dirty place to be
involved or you know it's not for good
people like me now but before I do I'll
go and talk to Newton because he'd known
when he was younger and Newton the
ex-slave trader says no stay in the park
fight slavery commit your life to
getting rid of this evil well he did and
he teamed up with some remarkable women
in the days remarkable women Hannah
Moore one of the most gifted drama
people of a Time Communicator educator
the Thorntons who are the wealthiest
families in uh family in Europe banking
family in the world in other words they
resourced it
a terribly inconvenient but you had a
bunch of white privileged Christians led
by William Wilberforce they abolished
slavery the trade first and then slavery
itself horrendously they forked down so
much money that had impact the debt of
Britain for a long time when they ended
when they actually banned slavery
because they compensated the slave
owners
including the Church of England I'm
ashamed to say
well that's how bad that trade was they
didn't actually compensate the slaves
themselves had been set free for the
owners now more than that well so so why
do you so well here's a question and
it's worth it's worth delving into so
obviously Wilbur Force was off arguing
from at least to begin with something
approximating a minority position yeah
very much words but his words didn't
fall on deaf ears right he was able to
elicit an echo of conscience in the
people that he was faced well so to me
the consequence of that is or the reason
for that is that by that time
the notion that all human beings were
made in the image of God had permeated
the English narrative conscience
Consciousness enough so that when when
what that meant was made explicit by
someone like Wilberforce and people were
being called on their hypocrisy their
own conscience echoed the claim yep yeah
but there's another aspect to it that's
really interesting I'll just to finish
on what Britain then did yeah is to try
to end it everywhere else and so they
sent the most powerful navy in the world
to freeze you know to stop slavery on
the high seas and a lot of white Sailors
died were they racist because they were
white males no dying to end black
slavery so this is much more nuanced I
mean this this idea of calling out One
race against another for all the evils
of the world is it does not Stack Up For
a Moment now to come back to your
question because it's Jermaine to that
I reckon it would be fair to say that it
did start to fall on fertile ears but
the shocking part of it was that he was
saying it's not just we weren't
Europeans who are human beings who need
to be valued see what I'm saying he's
saying that these people who are
regarded as less than human the Africans
were also fully human
and the famous text is from Galatians
for we're no longer slave and free we're
no longer Gentile or Jew we're no longer
man and woman we're all one in Christ in
other words all equal value God doesn't
discriminate loves each of his creations
and and and loathes it when they violent
to one another that's that's what he
took out of it he went away and studied
he wrote a book you can still get a
modern translation of it called real
Christianity and the subtitle is the
difference between what people think it
is and what it really is and that was
very interesting in itself and one of
his great supporters was Josiah Wedgwood
the pottery maker and he struck what is
regarded by a lot of people historians
as the first political slogan in
brilliant piece of pottery incredibly
intricate bass relief I think that's the
word you used for of uh of an African
man looking up pleadingly
it's incredibly lifelike it's a
beautiful piece of work you know and
it's it's white on on the Wedgwood blue
background and the thing underneath it
is not am I not a man and a brother
right now this is really radical stuff
but it's fantastic stuff and Churchill
said when a culture stops talking about
its history to its children
the story of its beliefs and its Heroes
it's saying they null and void and young
people don't have a sense of place and
they're thus open to Karl Marxist dictum
that a people that don't know their
history are easily persuaded yes we
don't know any of us what a Heroes will
be Force this guy could have had the
life of Riley could have been prime
minister got his hands on those levers
of power but he dedicated his life it's
successfully as a very wealthy man a
very privileged man
to people who were not regarded as full
members of the Human family right right
well I think why would you not be
inspired by slavery for what 175 years
on the high seas if I remember correctly
sorry the British fought slavery for a
long time 75 years well they were still
fighting it well right I mean we did we
thought it had gone in Australia the
Australian federal police were called to
a house in 1975 in the suburbs of Sydney
because there was a story going around
there that was a brothel that had slaves
in it the police said no no no that's
that's slavery in Australia and they
turned up there they've been told they
were 20 but they were 23. it was true
and we started to realize we had to pass
laws because there was no laws against
slavery in Australia there were no laws
so we assumed it didn't happen anymore
and now we know there's 45 million
Indian there's a lot of them I've been
trying to think through
you talked about this book Wilberforce
wrote about let's say true Christianity
and I've been trying to think through
what it might mean practically
and and
graspably I suppose
that each person is in some sense of of
axiomatic worth thing yeah that that's
the axis around which all belief must
turn all productive belief and so I
think it has something to do with the
nature of Consciousness itself
where all of us are very particularized
creatures right so we're only going to
make ourselves manifest in the world
once we're a very unlikely combination
of of genetic improbability and so
biologically we're each unique and then
the circumstances we're thrown into are
also unique and so that's where each the
conjunction of two unique
situations let's say highly unique and
but each of us
within those unique circumstances with
those unique talents have to Grapple
with
let's say we have to Grapple with the
possibility that's laid out in front of
us and we each have to do that in a
particularized way and if I
as a conscious being if I grapple with
the possibility that lays itself out in
front of me I can bring something into
being that only I can bring into being
because I'm particularized and then the
thing that's so remarkable about that is
that because I can communicate and
that's part of this fact that I'm imbued
with this logos which is really the
capacity to communicate if I create
something unique if I realize something
unique because of that particularity
I can then share it with other people
yeah and so that means they can weirdly
even though we're all particularized we
can all benefit from the the operation
of our own particularity yeah and you
know there's this idea
that's deeply embedded in the Christian
belief system that whatever Christ is is
the word that generates order out of
chaos made flesh right and then he's God
himself which is the process that
generates habitable order out of Chaos
made human and it's a very interesting
idea because what it means is that
there's a universal principle that's the
logos itself the word that Finds Its
embodiment in the particularities of
time and place right so that unites
let's say a little town in the Middle
East 2000 years ago with the Divine
itself and that's a model for a human
being is that we each embody this
process of encountering chaos and
potential and transforming it into
habitable order that's what's laid out
in Genesis 1 and we each do that in a
way that's communicable and that's
universally valuable because we can
share it and insofar as our societies
are set up
to insist that that be allowed to happen
then our societies can be productive
reciprocal and generous and then we can
operate collectively to compete and
cooperate in a manner that elevates all
of us and I don't think any of that's
arbitrary that's so when we're talking
about it seems necessary that every
culture has to establish itself in
relationship to something like axiomatic
presuppositions you have to make some
presuppositions maybe the left makes the
presupposition that the mode of force of
the world is power it's something like
that certainly the postmodernists do
that but you could say that well Western
culture insofar as it's been Guided by
the highest possible Spirit has made the
axiomatic presumption that every person
is of a Divine value and that means they
have something that's intrinsically
valuable to offer to bring into reality
itself that's why you're not supposed to
hide your light under a bushel let's say
and then I think you can make a very
practical case that
well isn't it valuable to learn from the
particularized experience of someone
else I mean what a unbelievable
advantage that is is that I can sit here
and talk to you yeah and everything that
you had to learn painfully
you can communicate to me and if I have
any sense at all I can listen and then I
can learn that without having to undergo
all that suffering and then you might
think well isn't it the case that if we
set up societies on that basis so that
everybody is regarded as
a valid source of Redemptive information
we can all exchange that and isn't that
the proper Pathway to life more abundant
and peace and generous
reciprocity that all seems to me to be
just true and that's instantiated in
voluntary
free market economies fundamentally
because we get to freely exchange the
the goods that we can freely produce so
we can both profit so yes and so that
yes and and more than that even I would
say so that we can both profit in a way
that helps us walk uphill
more and more efficiently and that we
can both do that in a way that's
simultaneously good for everyone around
us we can actually do that and and
and I don't think any of that's
arbitrary and so one of the things
that's worth pointing out is that
if your stated goal is something like
the removal of Oppression we can say
well congratulations to you you're not
on the sides of the tyrants but if the
consequence of your critique of Western
Civilization is that you throw the baby
the Divine baby we might say out with
the bath water
and you don't recognize that this
insistence on the intrinsic worth of
each individual is actually a
precondition for the for the for the for
your for your objection to slavery
you're going to destroy the very thing
that you think that you're promoting I
think we're doing that right I think
we're doing that is what I think we're
doing yeah yeah that's odd
you put it beautifully and I agree with
what I've understood you've said but
I'll just add to it how stupid are we if
we not only fail to learn from one
another but we won't bring back the
great figures of history and the
learning of time to the table for their
wisdom as well why not tap into that
well that's I will avoid it educated
yeah well we can we can we're certainly
do that doing that with regard to
Wilberforce that's my point well it's
it's kind of a miracle in some sense and
I I truly don't understand this you know
I was in the UK earlier this year and I
went to one of the Chapels there that
had a I think it was in Oxford but might
have been in Cambridge that had a statue
of Wilberforce you know and that was a
rather emotional moment for me because I
know that he was he was a stunningly
remarkable person yeah and it was out of
his efforts that well that Britain
organized himself for 175 years to
suppress slavery and so with these
teammates right right just like budget
repair in Australia it's a team and also
with with his alliance with great
figures of the past I mean his morality
was informed by his Christian faith and
that emerged out of this great
judeo-christian tradition I mean he
didn't do that he he did that by
allowing that Spirit to inhabit him he
didn't do that on his own right so but
but what I can't I really can't
understand
it's very difficult for me to understand
why that story isn't more well known and
more celebrated especially among people
who purport to
be advancing the doctrine that we need
to fight against oppressions like well
here's a man who did it
here's why he did it the historical
evidence on that is quite clear and like
you said it's a perverse story because
he was extremely entitled and an
attractive person and put a wild away
his dog penniless he gave it all away
huh
ah so why don't we teach that story like
what the hell is going on exactly why
would that be suppressed in some real
sense it's really quite stunning it is
stunning and it troubles me deeply and
perhaps Jordan it's because it raises
the question is of this
was the Christ that he believed in real
and oh no we don't want to confront that
possibility but I say
personally I think every one of us
should
well it works seemed to work for
Wilberforce and so you know I've been
I've been thinking about this in in
detail too and so
of course these questions always hinge
on what you mean by real but I would say
that
pain is pretty real
everybody acts as if that's true that's
for sure right we feel everyone acts
like pain is real and so then you might
say well
if pain is real what what allows you to
cope with pain or transcend pain must be
more real because if if something's real
and you encounter something that is more
significant than that you have to
attribute reality that so I just walked
Via Dolorosa the Stations of the Cross
with Jonathan pajo in Jerusalem and uh
whether or not the events that took
place at each of these stations actually
took place there is in some sense beside
the point you can think about it as a
dramatic Forum Jerusalem itself and if
you're a pilgrim you can go walk through
this catastrophic story of tragic
suffering and because I'm a psychologist
I'm always thinking well what exactly
strip away the religious issue for for
the moment what exactly are people doing
when they apprehend the figure of the
crucifixion and when they do something
like
consider Christ's passion or walk the
Stations of the Cross what are they
doing psychologically
and I actually think it's quite clear
I think that what people are doing is
voluntarily exposing themselves
to
a portrait of tragic suffering
and and more than that there's there's
more to it than that but that's a good
place to start it's like let's say we
all have to deal with the catastrophe of
life with the pain and limitation of
life
and so then you might say well how do
you do that how is it even possible to
do that and one answer might be
hide from it bury your head in the sand
and I'm not being smart about this it's
like the less you think about your
mortal vulnerability the better off
you'll be it's an insoluble problem your
best bet is to run away from that
realization to keep yourself blind and
maybe to busy yourself with as much
hedonic pleasure as you can possibly
know Drown Your Sorrows well and and and
that's understandable right you can say
okay well that a case can be made for
that but it's not a very psychologically
astute case because one of the things
that psychologists have figured out in
the last hundred years is that if you
want to stabilize people psychologically
and if you want to imbue them with
courage
then what you do is you help them expose
themselves voluntarily to the things
they're afraid of that they're avoiding
it's a very powerful technique that's
exposure therapy and what exposure
therapy seems to do is to make people
braver and
I'll tell you how exposure therapy works
because it's no joke so I had a client
who is afraid that he would cut himself
and he was afraid that if he was on the
top of a building
that he would jump off to his death and
one of the exercises we worked out was
that he would sit at the top of his
building near the edge with a knife
right and that's a very frightening
thing to do as a therapist because he's
saying look I have this impulse too
slash my throat and to jump off a
building and I thought well why don't
you confront both of those things at the
same time now we worked up to that you
know but I'm I'm just using that as an
example to show you how intense that
exposure therapy can be it's like we
need to identify what okay so then you
might think well what are people most
fundamentally fundamentally afraid of
and I would say well it's something like
pain and death and then even more
particularly it's unjust pain and death
and that's really at the core of the
crucifixion image and story because it's
unjust suffering and death and so the
psychological
what would you say why do
why have people been compelled to gaze
upon this image of unjust suffering and
the answer is something like
the best way to adapt to life is to Gaze
on the image of unjust suffering to do
that fully and I think that's true no
there's this strange idea too and this
is a very strange idea that the spirit
that guides the Israelites out of the
desert say in The Exodus story so the
spirit that stands against tyranny and
that stands against slavery is the same
spirit that confronts tragic mortality
voluntarily right there's an equation
that's the equation of the New Testament
in the Old Testament and I also think
that's
that's likely true that the pattern that
calls
to us from within
to object to tyranny and slavery
is the same pattern that
enables us to have the courage to look
upon our own mortality like forthrightly
and I would say that has to be that way
to some degree because
imagine you want to stand up to a tyrant
well you're gonna you could put your
life at risk to do that right I mean if
you're gonna speak truth to power you
know to use that terrible cliche
you're going to have to face the fact
that you might be hurt and even killed
in doing so and so how can it be
different to face the
inevitability of your own mortality for
a mortal for a moral cause and and stand
up to a tyrant those have to be the same
thing and so I would say it's time for
all of us to learn that these axiomatic
presuppositions like the idea that
part of what
gives us intrinsic value is the fact
that we're reflections of the word made
flesh that's actually that actually
turns out to be true it's not just uh
it's true in the deepest possible sense
and if we abandon that which is what
we're doing we're not going to eradicate
tyranny we're going to fall prey to it
and the fruit of abandoning it is all
around us and it's wrong
you know the misery is extraordinary but
you see I mean I I think
if I could respond
you're talking to somebody of course who
believes that that gospel story is
actually true I should say that right up
front
and
as you and I have talked about
people actually some say they say it to
my face sometimes I don't want to say
this gently I don't want to say
judgmentally but they they say oh John
you wouldn't know what suffering is look
at you you've had everything you know
yeah that's easy to say about someone
else well on the surface of it look I'm
privileged just to be an Australian
right right I've enjoyed good health for
that one of the happy marriage I have
four kids or grandkids are yeah had
opportunity bar claim but I've known by
some right right not many right right I
think there's about five out there
somewhere
um including the dog who loves me
because I feed him um but but I have
known real suffering I've known pain and
I've had to Grapple with it and I've had
to ask why suffering well I think we
bring suffering on ourselves because
we are so selfish it's an old-fashioned
word for it called sin but we're
self-centered
but then does anybody understand well I
think the Christ understands I Think
Jesus does a that that's the thing I've
come to realize that's been so humbling
when I thought poor little me I have
suffered and you know by any stretch of
decent evaluation I've known some pretty
awful things times you know
lost and what have you but
what we see there is a picture of of the
god man knowing Injustice that exceeds
any Injustice I've done
loneliness that exceeds any loneliness
that I'd done and loneliness is a
Dreadful thing
and pain physical and emotional beyond
anything that I can compare myself to in
order
of all those things in some real sense
and you're taking that on himself I I
then and in a way that I don't fully
pretend to be able to explain I can
place that back on him and because he
rose he's not captured by it
um we can rise too
and
that's to me yeah well it's something
like it's something the most important
issue that each of us need to Grapple
with can this possibly be true well it's
something like
it's like it's something like adopting a
form of metaphysical courage that's
Transcendent right because
let's say you have to take on the
suffering of your own life forthrightly
and and to the degree that you're able
to do that you you'll be able to
to maintain your moral compass despite
your suffering and maybe work to
ameliorate it and in order to do that
you have to adopt a particular pattern
of being and that pattern of being isn't
it isn't just unique to you like you
have to manifest it in your own life but
the pattern is universal and it's divine
and sacred for exactly that reason and
the pattern is something like forthright
confrontation with those things that
terrify you so there's a story this is
very cool and some people have heard me
talk about this before and maybe we can
close with this here's something that
I've been chewing on that's quite the
miracle
and I don't know how else to really
explain it so
when the Israelites are lost in the
desert
um they start to become fractious and
Idol worshiping and so they they fall
pretty the old ideological possession
fundamentally they lose faith in the
spirit that brought them out of tyranny
and no wonder because they're in the
desert it's like they're not having a
good time so it's no wonder they get
faithless but what happens when they get
faithless is that God sends poisonous
snakes in to bite them and you might
think well that doesn't reflect very
well on God and that's one of the
interesting things about the Bible is
that there are plenty of stories that
have that strange paradoxical twist it
doesn't matter the story really means
that just because you're lost doesn't
mean there isn't something stupid you
can do to make it worse and so and
faithlessness will certainly make it
worse and so God sends in these boys and
snakes and the Israelites are getting
bitten pretty good and so they go to
Moses
and they say look we're sorry that we're
so faithless and useless and fractious
and divided but you know the snakes are
getting a bit much so maybe go have a
chat with God and get him to call them
off
and so Moses says okay and he goes and
talks to God and God says God's
you know he's irritated with the
Israelites but he can be bargained with
apparently and uh
and Moses makes the case for the
Israelites he said they've been punished
enough and God what should happen or
what could happen is that God just gets
rid of the snakes because he sent them
to begin with he can just chase them
away but that isn't what happens and
this is very strange and I defy anyone
to come up with a simple explanation for
this because it's really something
uncanny so what God tells Moses to do is
to make a bronze
stake a staff which is like the staff of
Moses and it's like the tree of life
that's another way of thinking about it
or the tree of the knowledge of Good and
Evil to make a staff out of bronze and
then to cast a serpent in bronze and to
put the serpent on the on the on the
staff and then to have the Israelites
come and look at the serpent
and if they look at the serpent then the
poison will no longer destroy them so it
doesn't get rid of the poison he doesn't
get rid of the snakes what he does
instead is he gets the Israelites to
gaze upon that which poisons them and
the consequence of that is that they'll
be strengthened and that's this now the
cool Twist on this is that
that's what Christ says about himself
like thousands of years later he says
unless his image is lifted up the same
way the Serpent's image was lifted up in
the desert that there's no possibility
of redemption now that's a very weird
juxtaposition of ideas right because you
think well what the hell's going on in
the desert and what's up with the bronze
snake that's a mystery in and of itself
which I think is associated with the
necessity of facing that which can bite
you right to to pay attention to it to
adopt a stance of challenge in
relationship to it it's very deep idea
but then to
make the case that that's analogous in
some sense to the crucifix that's an
unbelievably sophisticated psychological
move because you might say well
what's the sum total of all snakes
and I think you can make a very
straightforward and compelling
psychological case that
there there's no confrontation that's
more ridden with snakes than the
confrontation that's laid out in the
story of the passion it's a limit story
so it takes all possible snakes into
account betrayal death at the hands of
the mob innocent suffering like you name
it
part of the suffering in that story so
it takes that snake and it makes it into
a meta snake and it says well it's one
thing to look at just a snake and to get
braver as a consequence but you should
instead look at the mother of all snakes
and get as Brave as that could possibly
make you and then you think well
if you're going to cope successfully
with your life with all of its
particularized catastrophes
do you really think that you're going to
be able to manage that without admitting
that the problems are there
who in the world would ever think that
and so then is it not the case that you
have to look at what's darkest in order
to be able to contend with it
and and these and then you might say if
that's the spirit that redeems you in
what Manner is that not a sacred Spirit
if it's the universal Pathway to
redemption in the face of suffering
which seems to be the case on
psychological grounds as far as I can
tell then I don't see how you can claim
that that's not
real true
foundational all of that I can't see a
ray out of that strange conundrum so
well I think
the thing that I would say I think is
that when you look into that darkness
and into that uh into that pain you've
got to recognize your own role in it
yeah and the answer
is to flee to someone
who offers Redemption and restoration
and the ultimate return
to you being the person that you should
have been and each of us is fearfully
and wonderfully made and absolutely
magnificent flawed as we are by our own
failings we are in my view an
extraordinary combination of unique made
in the image of a higher being destroyed
by our own selfishness but offered the
opportunity to return that is my
perspective and well I think that partly
what happens if you do look very deeply
into the suffering that characterizes
your life is that one of the things that
will happen is that you will start to
understand the rule you play in that
suffering yeah right and like life seems
to have an arbitrary element and you
know there's plenty of sick children who
don't seem to deserve it morally let's
say but when you look very hard at
your own suffering
and you contemplate it the probability
that you're going to see some causal
rule that you've played is pretty high
and then you have the option then of
not doing that anymore and that's
something like confession and Redemption
and and that's something like also
following this Divine pattern right is
to
stop doing those things that are dooming
you to unnecessary suffering and one of
the things I've wondered about for a
long time is that if you if you stop
doing everything that you could that was
off Target
even by your own criteria if you stop
doing all of that
how much suffering would be alleviated
not only for you right but for the
people around you and well not all of it
well well most of it well yeah and an
indefinite amount of it right because it
also seems like that's a sort of
struggle without end is that you can get
better and better at it and you can get
more productive and you can get more
generous and you can get better at
staving off suffering and it can get
more helpful to other people into
yourself we don't know what the upper
end of that is I met I met a fellow once
and he said he's an old man so not as a
young man I was knocking on those
inviting people to come and worship in
our church in Edinburgh
he said I knocked on the door and an old
man came out
and he said uh no I'm not interested in
God I was in the trenches the first
World War I don't want to know but I
stopped believing in God
and this young father said to him
I can understand you're hurt
can I just ask you how you would react
if I were to say to you that I think if
I'd been in the trenches I would have
stopped believing in man
ah
and he said the old father teared up
he said you better come and I want to
talk
and so we need to be much more honest
with ourselves I think and I think the
thing that I would say is that hope is
so important
and for me the hope is the Eternal hope
for me
and the only thing I would say humbly to
others is um
think carefully before you dismiss it
too right right I've had to try and make
sense of the conundrum that is life of
Good and Evil of joy and of pain
and what keeps me going is the secure
hope it is for me very real that the
wounds will be bound up and the joy will
be complete and I'll be the person I
should have been
a lot of people would be very relieved
to hear that
but and restored in relationship yeah
well part of that is the injunction we
talked about earlier not to throw the
baby out with the bathwater it's like
you know we should all be concerned
about the continuing possibility of
atrocity and oppression in the world but
then and we should be very cognizant of
the rule our own cultures
the cultures that have delivered to us
our privileged let's say that have
played in maintaining that oppressive
regime but at the same time we should
very carefully
differentiate what has been done that's
been right and good and Wilberforce is a
great example of that are they fruits it
is right and we sort of say oh Sansa was
a religious not look what I did yeah
look at the Towering figures just think
of them yes and then ask yourself in all
seriousness if you could have done as
well he was followed by Lord shaftesbury
another privileged man who've got the
kids out of the mines and out of the
chimneys and got some basic rights for
women and some labor laws at work
right and we could probably could do as
well in our own life all right Mr
Anderson I've enjoyed it here to you as
always you bet you bet and so thank you
all
um on YouTube and the other platforms
that you're listening to or watching
through for participating in this
conversation and we hope that it was
useful I'm gonna spend some time talking
to Mr Anderson on The Daily wire plus
platform at a more biographical level
talk to him a little bit about the
journey in his life that took him to
to the places that he's been in helped
him draw the conclusions that he's drawn
and that'll take place on The Daily wire
plus platform and thank you to them for
facilitating this conversation and
making it possible technically and
practically and to all of those of you
who are listening and watching
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com